l'insertion professionnelle des
Réunionnais fait partie des principal
mission du département en 2014 la
collectivité a financé les allocations
de solidarité à hauteur de 38,5 million
d'euros pour mener une politique
efficace et cohérente le département
mise sur l'insertion des publics en
difficulté tout en agissant sur
l'économie dans les domaines du service
à la personne ou du tourisme mais aussi
à travers ver le challenge des créateurs
l'insertion par l'économie est favorisée
à l'entre deux Daisy s'occupe de sa
maman atteinte d'alzheimer depuis 2 ans
une aide à pleint temps facilitée par le
versement de la PA comme je savais pas
quoi faire moi j'ai écrit au conseil
général j'ai demander de me conseiller
et ils m'ont fait un dossier en me
disant ben voilà que je pourvais aider
prendre ma mère etercevoir un petit peu
d'AP pour m'occuper d'elle je pense que
oui un jour je pourrais la mettre en
foyer mais ce serait vraiment la fin
parce que bien sûr est bien par si elle
en un AFF qui va pas elle est juste à
côté ma chambre là c'est c'est sa ch
mais elle n pas loin pour arrivriver
moin en matière de tourisme la filière
boî goyavier est un exemple d'insertion
par l'économie en plein développement
elle a tous les atouts nécessaires pour
séduire les touristes venus se mettre au
verre dans les jardin du VVF à
l'Ermitage les agents installent en ce
moment des cabanes perchées réalisé à
part de bois pays une première qui
répond à une véritable demande
oui la demande elle est là les gens qui
passent ils peuvent pas s'empêcher de
tourner la tête et de venir poser des
questions et de demander à quel prix
combien ça coûte une cabane comme ça et
je veux dire un prix comme ça entre un
hit Bélier à 5000 € et une cabane
perchée ou une cabane PMR à 50000 50 m²
enfin à travers le challenge des
créateurs un coup de pouce est apporté
aux personnes en recherche d'emploi qui
ont créé leur entreprise Marie Daniel
Merka à la tête des éditions la plume et
le parchemin est une des lauréates 2014
j'ai une période de
chômage pendant laquelle j'ai été auteur
en fait j'ai écrit plusieurs livres et
j'ai rencontré d'autres auteurs dans le
même cas et du coup ben j'ai voilà voulu
créer ce projet là en fait et puis créer
mon propre emploi aussi voilà alors le
challenge de créateur m'a apporté bon
une reconnaissance énorme donc voilà le
prix de de l'insertion pour moi c'est
c'est le plus beau après tout ce combat
que que j'ai mené avant j'étais toujours
à courir derrière tout le monde et là
maintenant on m'appelle pour me dire
viens faire des ateliers viens te
présenter et cetera c'est c'est vraiment
énorme voilà ça va
j'espère permettre de développer tout ce
que tout ce jeis professionnaliser les
publics en recherche d'emploi agir sur
l'économie et développer des filières
d'avenir tels sont les objectifs
poursuivi par le Département grâce à
l'insertion par
l'économie